and you drove from Michigan to New York.
How long was your drive?
- Nine hours or something.
- I love it.
- Oh my God.
- We're so symbiotic on this Friday.
Noor, why don't you tell
everybody your full name,
what you do, what you're about,
a little bit about yourself,
then we'll get into some questions
that everybody's watching live
start putting your phone numbers in
and what you wanna ask about
Andy K will take some questions,
I want to do a little
bit of more questions
than we've been doing lately.
- Okay, so my name is Noor Stars--
- [Gary] Why don't you
put the mike to you,
'cause I've noticed people
have been crying about that.
- Is it like this?
Am I good now?
- [Gary] Yeah, I think,
probably just a hint up?
- Hi.
- [Gary] Yeah, good.
- Okay.
- [Gary] Yes, Noor Stars.
- My name is Noor Stars, I'm a YouTuber,
I started on YouTube actually.
- [Gary] When?
- 2014, when I first moved
to the United States,
I was in high school.
And actually I started,
Sinan asked me something
about like English,
did I learn it by myself.
When I first moved to the United States,
my English was really basic.
Basic in a very early basic, you know,
like I know bread, tomato, how are you,
my name is blah blah blah, and you know--
- [Gary] Where did you grow
up, where where you born?
- So I was born in Iraq
and then we left from
Iraq to Syria as refugees.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And then I grew up like in Syria
and then the war happened in Syria,
we left from Syria to
Turkey as also refugees.
I lived also in Turkey
for like a couple of years
and then we came to America as refugees.
- [Gary] Right, so
you're a triple refugee.
- Yeah (laughs).
- Amazing.
I know, and I--
- You know, I came to
America as a refugee.
- Yeah, and that's why I can relate to you
when you talk about
like starting from zero
on coming to this country.
You came here with your
family, you started from zero,
you worked so hard and look at you now.
So that inspires me a lot, Gary,
and that's why I am here now,
because I love you a lot.
- Thank you very much, I love you back.
So you come to the US,
you know, you're young the whole time,
but out of my own curiosity,
'cause I'm so fascinated by this story,
which was the biggest culture shock?
I know you were young all along,
but was the jump from Iraq
to Syria, Syria to Turkey,
Turkey to the US, what was
the biggest difference?
- Turkey.
- From Syria to Turkey.
- From Syria to Turkey, because--
- Why?
Even more than Turkey to the US?
- Yes.
- Go ahead.
- Because Turkey was very shocking to me,
it's a new language.
It's not English, I had to
learn a new language from zero,
to communicate with people.
And I was very young,
I went to Turkey when I
was like 14, fifteen-ish.
It was my first job there, it
was very tough as a refugee.
It's literally, you're by your own,
by yourself, you know.
And I found myself very responsible,
I mean in Syria, I was a very
responsible girl growing up,
because I grew up with a single mom.
But in Turkey it's like
my mom couldn't hug me,
because she doesn't know how to hug me.
So it's like I have to help everyone,
and that's why it was the hardest.
- [Gary] It's cool.
- America, though, I was
kind of ready for it,
'cause I already learned a lot in Turkey.
So that's why Turkey was hardest.
- Makes sense, really cool.
So you get here and you go where?
- First I went to
Seattle, but not Seattle,
like it's a small city around Seattle.
- Washington State.
- Washington State, yeah.
Usually when you're a refugee
they put you in like a small city.
- [Gary] Yeah, to get acclimated.
- Yeah, but it wasn't easy, it was tough.
So we moved to Michigan,
because it has more Arabs,
and my mom at least can communicate.
- [Gary] Yeah, of course.
- So I studied in Michigan High School.
- [Gary] Awesome.
- And my English was very basic,
and I love to talk, Gary.
That's why I'm a YouTuber.
I feel like that's what helped me
become such a good YouTuber, because--
- I fear losing my voice more than dying.
- [Noor] Yeah, right.
- Like if I couldn't talk,
that would just be like--
- That's it, we're done (laughs).
- I mean I'd probably do
some Stephen Hawking shit
and figure it out, but like,
it would crush my soul.
- [Noor] Yes, I love to talk.
- I mean high school's
already tough to begin with
for people that grow up here,
like how was your Michigan
high school experience?
- Oh my God, yeah, as you
said, it's tough by itself.
So imagine being in high
school without the language.
And people talk and I'm
like what are you saying?
I don't understand, like uh, what is this?
And I went to high school
with the the mindset
of a Middle-Eastern Arab girl,
so I was like, what is he saying?
Flirting, what's flirting?
I don't get it, like no.
So I was kind of aggressive
and with no language.
It was a hard time and I
remember I went to my teacher
and I was like, look man, I need to speak.
He keep teaching me like grammar,
what can I do with the grammar,
grammar doesn't help me.
- Fuck sentences, I need
to be talking to people.
- Yeah, I wanna talk,
right, I want to speak.
And I'm like I need to
speak, I wanna talk to you.
And he goes like you
have to do extra work.
I'm like, I'm ready,
give me the extra work.
- Like I fuckin' worked in Turkey, bro.
- Yeah, like I wanna learn the language,
and he goes like here,
there's these websites,
and listen to music and lyrics,
and movies and all of
that and then YouTube,
and he'll give me something on YouTube,
and that's when I started
binge watching YouTube.
And I kinda like watched YouTube before,
but not focused watching YouTube.
And when I moved to America
I had a lot of free time,
so I used it, I watched a lot.
And I remember the first
YouTuber and YouTube video
that I watched for a
YouTuber that made me like--
- [Gary] What is this!
- Wait, what is this!
Exactly, it was from Michelle
Phan, you know Michelle Phan?
- [Gary] Yes, of course.
- She's one of the, I met
her last year at VidCon.
- [Gary] You were pumped?
- I waited for her and she
came and she's like hi,
and I was with the Middle East team
from like Facebook and Instagram,
and I'm like, guys, leave,
I'm here for something,
and they were like what's up,
and I met her.
- That's awesome.
And I'm like you don't understand,
your video, the Spanish makeup
I still remember the video.
That was the moment when I
was like, that's so cool,
and I wanna do that.
I always wanted to do like,
I always wanted to be in
the entertainment industry.
But everyone told me it's impossible,
'cause I'm an Arab girl, first of all--
- Yes, I'm aware of the
political climate in America.
- So this is first of all,
not only in America,
it's just the culture, you know,
it's hard for a girl,
like when I started YouTube,
girls were only showing
their hands on the internet.
Rarely you see a girl with her face.
- [Gary] You mean--
- In my culture, yeah.
It's hard, like now it's better now,
I see girls on YouTube, on
social media, and I'm like wow,
it's really, we kind of
helped changing this mindset
and we're still like trying
to, but like from all aspects.
It's like, Noor, impossible,
go study medical,
become a doctor, you go to school,
and I was really good at school,
straight A student, typical Arab family,
but honestly I did it for my mom,
'cause I wanted her to be proud.
- [Gary] Of course, of course.
- So I always like get As,
and yeah, become a doctor, that's it.
But that's not what I
loved, I didn't wanna.
- So what happened next?
You saw the Michelle Phan video,
how quickly before you
made your first video.
- Very quick.
- [Gary] The next day?
- Yeah, literally, I made a video
and I remember looking at it
and being like, oh my God,
I'm gonna put my face on the internet?
You know what I mean,
I used to put my face
on Facebook on private,
only specific people see.
- Of course, of course, it's cultural.
But you also were recognizing
that you were in a new
environment in the US
that did change,
like it would have been
far harder to do that.
- And I was so lonely, Gary,
honestly, it was a lonely time for me.
- Look, listen, I know
you know my content,
a lot of the stuff I say, you know,
is counter to what parents
and grownups are assuming.
They don't understand all the benefits
and virtues of the digital landscape.
They focus on negatives.
They're like, kids don't
know how to talk each other
without using technology.
I'm like yes, but what
about you sitting lonely
in Michigan in 1987?
You'd have stayed fucking lonely.
- Yeah, I was so lonely
and like very alone.
It was like, no English, and
that's why I started in Arabic.
- Interesting.
- Yeah, I started in my
language that I can do.
And even though it was tough,
like I was one of the
first girls on YouTube
showing their faces.
And I remember thinking, oh
my God, I'm gonna put this on.
At the same time I was saying to myself
I can always make it private.
- [Gary] Yeah, of course.
- So it's not gonna go
viral, who's gonna watch it,
you know, when you tell
yourself, who's gonna watch it?
And then I uploaded it
and I went and I came back
and I saw views and people commenting.
I got, of course, I got hate from people
saying why is this girl here?
But also I got a lot
of girls supporting me,
and that was shocking for me.
It's like girls, Noor,
we love you, don't stop,
we want you, we want you
to create more videos.
And I made my second video
and I made my third video
and there was no money, I
didn't know the money part.
- [Gary] Of course, that wasn't the point.
- No, I was in high school.
- How often did you post at that point?
- Not much, when I first started--
- Like once a month?
- I don't remember, but
like, not once a month,
'cause I enjoyed it, I loved
this, so maybe more than that.
And I got to a point where
I was the first YouTuber
at least in the Middle East
that was posting three times a week.
And other YouTubers,
like that was doing YouTube at the time,
they were like why is
this girl posting three,
'cause usually they post once
a week, once every two weeks,
and I'm like I love it, I'm
going to post more and more.
And that's when I passed everyone,
I start passing people
that has big numbers
or like have been on YouTube for years
and I'm like boom, boom, and they text me.
I remember like one YouTuber,
he was like bigger than me,
and I tried to talk to him,
and he's like he didn't talk to me.
And then when I passed
him he contacted me,
he's like, what tags do
you use for your video?
And I'm like, wait a
minute, tags, what's tags?
You know, the tags that you put under--
- [Gary] Yes, I've heard of tags.
- Now I know, I don't know
tags back then (laughs)
and I'm like tags, what's tags?
Then I googled what's
tags, 'cause I didn't know.
He's like, oh yeah, you
must be doing something.
And I'm like man, I don't have money,
They thought, I'm not
even, I don't have money.
When I first started I don't
have money to do anything.
I'm just posting.
- The big misconception is
quality content is always underrated,
people always think it's tactics.
And look, listen, as somebody
who won on not the tactics,
as I've built our capabilities,
whether it's thumbnails or
titles or understanding,
of course it's part of the equation,
but the art is such a
big part of the game.
And most people focus on the math
and you were winning on the art.
- Yeah, it's just like
I was creating content
that I really love and enjoy
and it was new to YouTube,
so people weren't like
thinking it will do well,
but it did really good.
- And what was new about it?
- Like I would just talk to the camera
and like just rant or tell them something
that happens to me.
Story, but that wasn't the storytime time,
but I was telling them story,
and they loved it, you know.
- When did you switch
from Arabic to English
on your channel?
- I don't make English videos.
- [Gary] You don't?
- No.
- To this day?
Oh I didn't know that.
- To this day, it's only Arabic, yeah.
- You've never made one?
Have you thought about it?
- I thought about it, actually.
- You know one of the things
that I'm always fascinated with,
a lot of the content
that'd be in the media,
you know, obviously an enormous
Latino population growing
and Spanish-speaking in America,
and for a lots of brands
were doing Spanglish.
Have you ever thought about doing a video
that mixes both languages?
You know, so at home, when
I speak with my parents,
we'll start a sentence in
English and finish in Russian.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Or you'll start telling
the story in Russian,
you'll finish it in English.
Or you'll literally go back and forth
within mid-sentences, right?
I think that's something worth debating.
And if nothing else,
if you think back to your earliest days,
one of the things that
very successful YouTubers,
Instagramers, people that
create content get caught up in
is they know at this point of
maturity, five years later,
you know what works,
and subconsciously you're at
your most, least creative place
because you're maximizing
on you knowing what worked.
Yet it was you knowing
nothing in the beginning,
that gave you the foundation.
- [Noor] It's so true.
- And I'm trying to encourage more,
I spoke at a YouTube off-site,
and it was all a crew of who's who,
and I was like the best
thing all of you can do,
is make a video tomorrow
that you know won't work.
- Wow, I like that, yeah,
because you know it'll work,
like I know if I'm making a video,
I know it's gonna get five millions
or ten millions or one million.
- You're subconsciously
already so close to it.
Which is what's stopping you
from making an English video,
even though you should.
- You think so?
- You know many people don't speak Arabic?
- I know a lot.
- Yes, I think so.
- And I live in America,
that's why people like,
when I tell them something--
- And more importantly
there are so many girls
like you guys who want to see both.
There's a 14 year-old girl right now
in the suburbs of London who,
she's 14, and in her household
the Arabic language has
not been upheld as much,
and she's 90% American,
excuse me, English-speaking,
she has 10% nuance of Arabic words
and she can't watch you
because you talk too fast
and have too much of vocabulary
she does not understand.
You know, look, I think both
of us fought to be here today.
- [Noor] Yeah, I know.
- You never know why,
and I appreciate you've
always given me a lot of love
and some nice messages and good vibes
and stuff of that nature.
- I love you, Gary, you know that.
- But I really genuinely
think if anything,
you producing English or
English-Arabic mix content
on YouTube ASAP, is super important.
- I was thinking of opening
like an English channel.
- [Gary] Don't.
- No?
- Try.
- On my channel?
- There's nothing that's,
listen, you know this,
you know, the five years
ago girl knows this.
Nothing's gonna happen.
- On my channel it's hard,
you know, it's Arabic,
some people don't speak English.
- It's not.
You're pandering to
the current viewership.
- [Noor] Yeah.
- It's not hard.
If 88% of them can't
understand the English?
You're opening up yourself
to the rest of the world.
- Yeah, I'm just like
'cause I worked so hard
for the channel to--
- Do you genuinely believe a single video
of you making English
eliminates all you've worked hard with?
I just posted a piece of
content on my Instagram
an hour ago,
that says I hate dogs.
I have hundreds of people right now
actively replying in my comments
saying unfollow, unfollow, unfollow.
I'm not scared of that,
I'm trying to make the point
of more love with each other,
not that I hate dogs,
though I'm not the biggest fan of dogs.
- I love dogs, Gary.
- [Gary] Listen, that's great.
- I love dogs.
- I love the New York Jets,
I mean like, everyone's allowed
to love different things.
My big point is though,
I posted it and the team sent it to me
and they didn't even put an asterisk
and they didn't even like,
the way they wanted to go about it,
I would have really lost,
I'd be completely managing right now,
but even though the way I hedged it,
but what I knew when I posted it
is if I can help one person
become a kinder person to another person,
it's worth the thousands
of people that I lose.
You're looking at defense.
You're saying to yourself I
worked so hard to do this,
that if I do something in English,
I may lose something,
the algorithm, subscribers,
some people that don't
want me to do English.
What you're not thinking about
is all the people that
you'd be bringing in.
- Yeah.
- When you have nothing,
you have nothing to lose,
which is why you're most creative.
When you have something,
you lose your creativity
because you have something to lose.
The words out of your mouth
was, I worked so hard.
- Yes, I did actually
and that's the thing,
after reaching 10 millions, Gary,
my goal was to reach 10 millions
and get the Diamond Play Button,
because I was the first to
get it in the Middle East.
- [Gary] Okay.
- So people, even when we have events
with YouTubers and all,
I told them I want the
Diamond Play Button,
they would laugh at me
because they're like,
no one did it before you,
and we don't know if
there's that many channels
in the Middle East, so we're not--
- [Gary] I understand.
- So they thought I'm crazy
for a while, and I did it.
And I was so happy when I
received the Diamond Play Button,
but then after that,
I had like a period of time
where I'm like, what's next?
- Noor, that's because you're
making too many decisions
on outside variables.
- [Noor] Like how?
- Easy, I've never thought
about a single number
financially or YouTube or
subscribers, or anything.
Because the reason you're not putting out
a piece of English content
is you're pandering
something to the outside
versus the only reason you
have that feeling of emptiness
or what's next, or what's the next goal,
whether it's good grades
to make your mom happy,
whether it's subscribers,
listen, I love proving people wrong,
I can tell that you're
very driven by that,
that's a a great thing, I love
that, that achieves a lot.
But at this point,
if you're able to start
changing it a little bit
and make it about what
you're trying to accomplish,
what do you want to say?
How much impact do you,
listen, if you want to impact, right?
- [Noor] Yes.
- Like when you have
this big of an audience
that you have right now,
I'm sure you'd walk around
knowing some sort of feeling
of a sense of responsibility.
- [Noor] Definitely.
- A sense of ambition, a sense of knowing,
wow, I can really make a difference,
you're limiting yourself
by not also using English,
since you, I wish I spoke all these.
If I spoke Mandarin, and I spoke Arabic,
I'd be fucking going
nuts, I'm actually trying,
I'm like devastated
that I can't speak Arabic.
I was just in Qatar the other day,
and I was like man,
anytime when I'm in Singapore,
I wish I could speak those languages,
for the sole reason
that I don't transcribe
to all these channels,
so that I could put it on my channel.
Here's why.
No one piece of content could
ever undo all your hard work.
- Yeah, let's see.
- Let's see what?
- You have a point.
- [Gary] I'm aware I have a point.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] I'm curious
about what's stopping you.
- See, the thing is like I
feel like I'm under pressure--
- [Gary] Makes sense.
- It's like I represent
the Middle East YouTubers--
- [Gary] Which is amazing.
- And I'm scared if I do it in English,
then they might think that,
oh my God, like, she's
leaving her culture.
- So listen, that makes
so much sense to me,
and honestly, this was the
first moment that I'm like,
oh, this is why she won,
the fact that you're brave enough
to tell the truth right now,
already excites the shit
out of me about you.
- [Noor] Thank you.
- That makes a ton of sense.
Couple of things.
There's a fuckload of
people in the Middle East
who speak English too.
I know this because I don't speak Arabic
and when I go there
and I love going there,
I'm able to communicate with
almost every fucking person.
English is one of the universal languages.
- That's why I wanted
to do English content,
because I'm like, I wanna reach everyone.
I wanna be able to speak to the world.
- The other thing is, you're so young
and have such a big platform,
we need to be in a place
where we don't have to
create separate channels,
because we're scared of the negative,
we need to start creating
content within our channels,
so that we make things more inclusive.
Like you have such a big
thing, you speak both.
- Yeah, and I speak some Turkish.
- I'm sure you did, Sinan
was all pumped about it.
- He was happy.
- And he speaks a little Thai.
Listen, I can't encourage
you enough to try it.
Here's why.
You already know the right answer.
You remember your first video?
You remember when you said to yourself,
I can always make it private?
- [Noor] Yeah.
- You can always not make
another English video
on your Arabic channel.
- Wow, oh my God, I love that.
It's like you can, oh, so try it.
You know, I'm gonna try it.
- [Gary] I believe you.
- I will.
- I will try it.
- And I have a funny
feeling it's gonna be great.
And the same thing that happened
on your first video's gonna happen.
Yes, there will be hundreds of comments,
like fuck this, you're selling out,
you're not representing,
and then you'll have a ton of people
that tell you that this
is huge and amazing
and you will impact and bring
more good to more people.
- [Noor] I'll try it.
- You will win the net game.
The reason I've always
won as a entrepreneur
is I think in net score.
Most people are worried
about winning one to zero,
or losing one to zero.
I'm worried about winning 11 to six.
That's what we just talked about.
(sighs)
Everybody thinks it's one zero.
Life is not one zero.
Life is 11 to six.
And that's what a successful navigator
of the opportunity is in my mind.
- Maybe that's why I drove nine hours
from Michigan to here.
- I think so.
We want questions, guys.
What else, tell me the breakthrough video.
We're gonna get some
phone numbers right now
and he's about to do a call,
but before we get to this first call,
everybody's got a breakthrough video.
Was it the third video,
the 19th, the first,
the five thousandth,
when was the video that was like, oh shit,
which was your first viral video?
- It was actually school tips.
- [Gary] School tips.
- Yeah, I remember, it went like,
it was the first video that
had like over a million,
I'm like, wait, a million people watched--
- And what were you getting
up to that point, 100,000, 50?
- Not even a 100,000, less.
- [Gary] Sixties and thirties--
- But the thing about me, Gary,
which is like I even didn't
understand at the beginning,
my numbers were like skyrocketing.
Like when people find me, they subscribe
and then I pass everyone
and I stayed number one
from five million till now.
So that's, I don't know,
don't ask me, about like--
- Well, you and your audience
connect with each other.
- Yeah, I feel like my
audience, they know,
not everything about me, mind you,
I don't have Draw My
Life video on my channel.
- Of course, of course.
- But they know some
things, like we connect.
- Yeah, anyway, Andy, let's
do the first question.
Noor, I really really encourage
you to, let me say this--
- I have a question.
- Yeah, we'll get to it, we'll get to it.
You shouldn't do an English
or a English-Arabic video
'cause I'm saying so,
(phone rings)
you should do it because
you want to try it.
And if you do wanna try
it, then you should do it.
- [Caller] Hello.
- Hello, who's this?
- [Caller] This is Cody, yeah.
- Cody, you're on with Gary
and Noor, please say hello.
- [Cody] Hey Gary, what's going on, man?
Hey Noor, how's it going?
- Hi, how are you?
- I'm good.
- What's your question, Cody?
- [Cody] Yeah, so I had
a couple of questions,
but I guess I'll go
with one question only?
- Whatever you want.
- [Cody] Yeah, so I operate
and own a restaurant full-time,
and then also tomorrow me and a partner
are starting a small
business marketing agency,
so I just want some tips
on staying motivated
and being accountable for myself,
so that I can do both businesses
and make both of them successful.
Sorry, I'm a little bit nervous.
- No, don't worry, Cody.
My question is the motivation part.
I mean, why wouldn't you be motivated?
- [Cody] No no, I'm definitely motivated,
but I guess being accountable and things--
- Are you worried about
juggling two things?
- [Cody] That's more of it, right.
45, 50 hours at one job
and then hopefully with the
new thing, 25 hours a week.
- I mean it becomes--
- [Cody] Actual productive hours.
- That's a really good point.
As long as you're staying,
look, when you're starting a new business,
they're all productive.
I think people don't understand that.
Because figuring out what isn't working
is almost as important
as figuring out what is working.
'Cause you don't know, it's all new.
Back to being creative in
the beginning with videos.
So I think that that's,
keep that in mind, brother,
that those 25 hours, 20 hours,
are all going to be valuable,
'cause you're learning,
you've never done client
services for small businesses,
you understand?
Number two, I think as
long as you're healthy
and keeping yourself healthy
and not burning out from
the sheer amount of hours,
then what you need to be figuring out
is how do you balance sleep and escapism.
Like do you need to watch the ballgame,
how much per night do you need to play,
what music do you need to listen to.
There's kind of like,
to me it's kind of like
three pillars, four here,
you've got two businesses,
they're pillars,
then there's your own kind
of health and happiness,
like do you get enough
exercise, sleep, and rest?
And then the fourth one is escapism.
Like, a lot of times
when people listen to me,
they only read the headline.
I don't want you to not not watch Netflix,
I don't want you to watch Netflix
if you're complaining and you're unhappy.
If you're happy, like I
watch the Jets every Sunday,
and there's nothing
anyone can do about it.
And I garage sale, and I
spent three and a half hours
looking up sports cards
last night on eBay.
I need my escapism to make me tick.
I'm just speaking to all the
people that aren't happy.
When you're not happy, you
need to judge your leisure.
Because when you're unhappy,
your leisure is your escapism
from your unhappiness.
- [Cody] Right, so a little background,
a year ago I had open heart surgery,
and once I recovered from that
I kind of got to the point
where all the stuff that I want to do,
I need to do it now, you know.
- Yeah, open heart surgery at a young age,
how old are you?
- [Cody] I'm 31.
- Right, open heart surgery at 30,
changes your perspective
real fucking quick.
- [Noor] Yes.
- [Cody] So I want to do all the stuff,
like one my goals to have
a few businesses by 2025.
- Hey Cody, your ultimate
goal has to be being happy.
- [Cody] Well, you know,
I think that's a tick,
I enjoy storytelling,
and the reason why I'm
doing marketing is--
- You enjoy it.
- [Cody] I thought I'd
do a lot of marketing
with the restaurant.
- Listen, listen, you're
talking to somebody
who went through it.
I thought I was building a wine business,
what I was building was
a storytelling platform
that built a huge wine business.
So I'm living what you're going through.
Let me just say this, though.
Because one of the things that
I've seen from my friends,
contemporaries, and business associates,
is when they have a near-death experience
or lose a very significant
loved one in their inner circle,
they put this disproportionate
amount of short-term pressure
on themselves, to get
everything accomplished
and I've seen it become
detrimental at times.
So just be thoughtful of,
to me this is why the process
and the journey and happiness
need to be the pillars of our society.
As long as even opening the
business is the success,
you are now playing with house money.
The reason I'm so happy, is I
think I play with house money.
Just being able to do the
things that I'm doing,
is what I want to be doing.
Not if they end up being successful.
- [Cody] Yeah, and I
enjoy the process too,
like building up the business,
and then donating to
something just like you do.
It's that thing for me,
and then wanting to
build something up again,
I think that's why I
wanna do the new thing.
Not that the restaurant is repetitive,
but I enjoyed making
it, it's successful now,
and then I wanna take on
something, another challenge.
- It makes all the sense in the world.
Listen, I'm gonna tell you something,
based on something we just talked about,
I would just not judge yourself,
I think you've got all the ingredients.
I think if you're capable
over the next three years
to not judge yourself,
for example, it's gonna be
easier to get small businesses
to use you for marketing
than keeping them.
Because small businesses
don't spend a lot of dollars
and it's hard to create real tractional,
like ROI in the short term.
And you're gonna land some
clients pretty quickly
off the success of your restaurant,
but then they're gonna
fire you after six months.
As long as you don't then,
when you get fired by
two clients in a week,
look yourself in the mirror
and say I'm a failure,
I wasn't able to keep
two things going at once,
as long as you're able to really balance
the judgment against yourself,
I have a feeling everything
else I've heard from you,
you're going to be in a great spot.
It is the one vulnerability,
the over-judgment on short-term losses
that are micro losses, not macro losses.
- [Cody] Winning in the aggregate, yeah.
- [Gary] Noor, anything to add?
- What you said is more than enough.
- [Cody] I appreciate it, Gary.
- You got it, Cody, take care,
let's go to the next question.
- I have a question.
- [Gary] Go ahead, you ask your question.
So you know, like, all I do is I create,
that's what I know.
- [Gary] Yeah, makes sense.
- I don't know, I tried to study business,
and a lot of people told me
you should have another source of income.
I don't know, how does that work?
- Well, a couple of things.
- What's another source of income?
- Well, listen, you know you
can start unlimited products,
you could start unlimited services,
you have unlimited opportunities.
You don't have to, though.
This is what makes me laugh about people.
Everybody thinks there's
some sort of blueprint.
You don't have to.
First of all, to your point, don't forget,
let's actually use the both of us.
I grew up always wanting
to be a businessman,
It never ran through my mind
that I wanted to go to Hollywood.
I never joined the drama
team, I didn't speak,
I got a D in speech.
I got a D, this is a
report card you never had.
I got a D in speech.
I'm legitimately one of the
real speakers in society,
and I got a D in speech.
But the internet created a
world where I became known.
So all the selfies and the notoriety
is not how I thought about it.
So it makes sense that I
know how to build businesses,
because I honed my skills in business,
I always wanted to be in business,
and this became a secondary thing.
For you, you always
dreamed to be in Hollywood.
You wanted to be creative, and
a personality or an actress,
or however you thought about it.
You aren't required to
start a beauty brand,
you're not required to
start a fashion brand,
you aren't required.
Now you may want to,
because it might be a fun new challenge.
You're such a young woman,
you may wake up in 10 years
and say I want a new challenge.
You also may have somebody in your circle
or somebody from the outside
that you get to know over five years,
that you say you wanna
go in business with them,
and he or she always wanted
to start a bottling water
company or a sneaker brand.
It's early for you.
- Really?
'cause I feel like the pressure,
'cause I'm the oldest in the family
and I'm like responsible
for a lot of things.
- Let me ask you a question,
I have a funny feeling that
your ad revenue from YouTube
is doing just fine.
- Yeah, it's good, and I have
sponsorships, I'm doing good,
but that's really what people say,
these are not guaranteed,
you should open a
business that guaranteed.
And it's like I don't know what to do.
- That is not true.
- [Noor] I don't know
like what else to do.
- They're wrong.
Your business is not guaranteed.
John Wayne was guaranteed to be famous,
not guaranteed to be a good businessman.
Brad Pitt is guaranteed
to be a famous person,
he's not guaranteed to
be a good businessman.
It's not smart thinking.
You may be capable of using the awareness
you have in your audience
to create businesses,
you also might want to triple down
on being awesome with your audience,
so that other businesses give
you money for sponsorship.
Too many people have
shifted to selling T-shirts,
hoodies, sneakers, candy, makeup,
and are actually leaving
money on the table,
and they're doing it for money,
because now they're
monetizing their audience,
their audience has other options to go,
so they're leaving them,
their sponsorship dollars are going down,
and they're not gonna build
a successful bottled water company.
- Wow, that's what, you
know I don't have merch.
I never created merch.
- I understand.
And people think I'm
crazy for not doing that.
And I'm like, I don't believe in it.
I don't wanna create something
with Noor Stars on it, like.
- There are so many, listen,
it's fun to have the team here.
Everybody sees us do cartoons,
sneakers, cereal, like wine,
people are oh my God, they do everything,
there's so many things
that we've been working on for two years
that never see the day of life.
- Yeah, but with you it's
different, this is your job,
you create products.
- It's what I love and
that's what I wanna do.
But even within it,
if I don't feel where I'm going with it,
is that if I don't feel good about it,
even if I felt good
about it when we started,
I have to feel good from the
moment it's an idea in my head,
to the moment--
- [Andy] Here's a funny story.
- Tell them.
- Tyler wanted to, we were
gonna release a T-shirt,
Gary's on board with it, long story short,
after four months we shelved.
G's at the shirt, is like
yeah, I'm not into it,
we're not going to do it.
And Tyler was just devastated.
(claps)
- That's right, 'cause
I live what I preach.
When I tell somebody the losses or the nos
are as valuable as the yeses, I pay Tyler.
Him spending four months on
that, is money I've lost.
Like I don't think people understand.
My entire world,
listen, one of the things
I'm quickly, you know,
intuitively I wanted you to hear,
but I'm quickly gaining insight to you,
listen to me, you're super young,
and I'm gonna use my leverage
of you looking up to me right now,
never ever ever do anything
you don't believe in.
It is the quickest way
to start the process
of losing everything you hold true.
- Yeah, that's my struggle now.
- [Gary] It's not a struggle.
- I don't want to do merch.
- [Gary] It's not a struggle,
it's not a struggle.
- It's hard sometimes to say no.
- [Gary] It's very hard to say no.
- It's like why, this
is money you're leaving.
- Let me give you a real
good one that I like to use
when somebody annoys
me, that's close to me.
Once in a blue moon,
if somebody's annoying me that I love,
that I love, who's trying
to get me to do something,
I look him in the face and say,
you become Gary Vee, and you do it.
- Oh, that's nice.
- So whoever's telling you to do it,
you tell them, you go amass
10 million subscribers
and you do it.
Right, John?
It's good.
It's good, like once in a blue moon,
if I really get, it's rare,
like when Andy is close enough to me now,
Brandon, my parent,
somebody really pushing me
and I'm like, you do it.
- Yes, oh my God, I have another question,
since you talked about your loved ones.
What do you do for your loved ones
that don't understand
that you're that busy?
They think you're just faking it,
or you don't want to spend time with them
when you're really busy, but
they don't understand that.
How do you deal with that?
- I make it clear with them.
- How, if they don't get it?
- By talking.
Well, if they don't
get it, that's on them,
that's not on me.
- [Noor] Yeah, yeah.
- That's not my problem.
- Like you know how our life
is busy and they don't get it,
they're like, why do you
have to work that much?
- Because you're happy.
- [Noor] I love it.
- The end.
- Yeah, and I love them
too, but I love my job,
I love what I do.
- Of course.
And there's also moments in time,
like you know, you'll get to a place
where there'll be full of three months
you're not loving it as much,
and you're missing your aunt
and you'll spend more time with her.
- That actually happened this Ramadan.
- [Gary] I believe you.
- You know, every Ramadan I have a goal
of uploading at least
20 videos, like 20, 25.
This Ramadan I uploaded
like seven, eight videos
because I wanted to spend
time with my family.
- [Gary] Good for you.
- And people are like,
what's happened to Noor,
because once I uploaded 30
videos on Ramadan in one month.
- Have you ever uploaded
in those scenarios
a video that says here's
what happened to me,
I've been reading your comments,
I just want to spend
more time with my family.
- I uploaded yesterday actually.
- [Gary] It's the best.
- I announced our show
and then I told them,
I'm really spending time with my family,
that's why I'm away.
- That's it, the end.
Your call.
- Yeah, another call.
- Listen, this is an inside game.
You can do the call.
Anytime you pander to anybody's
voice besides your own,
it always ends up wrong.
(phone rings)
that doesn't mean not
taking people's opinions
and being thoughtful,
but ultimately your decisions are yours.
- [Noor] Yeah.
- [Robert] Hello.
- Hey Robert, it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
You're on the Ask Gary
Vee show with me and Noor.
- [Robert] Hey how's it going, guys?
- Hi, how are you?
- We're doing well.
- [Robert] I'm doing great.
- What's your question?
- [Robert] My question,
Nora, it's for you,
you know, I've been in
the US since I was eight,
my parents brought me here
and I'm an undocumented
immigrant, I'm a dreamer,
and I just wanted to thank you first
for talking out about dealing
with fears of being alone.
And I just want to know like
how you pushed through that fear
because I'm dealing with the
fear of hiding, you know,
like that's my, that's how I'm
successful, I hide (laughs).
And I want to break out of that, you know.
- How do you think about that?
How do you think about breaking out of--
- [Noor] I don't understand his accent.
- His issue, and I don't
know your situation,
is being a dreamer at this point,
like there's still unsettled
business in America
on the dreamer situation.
So his reality is
he's gotta play in the shadows
a little bit while things get settled.
- Yes, right, do it like
this till you're ready to,
or till like people know by themselves
that you're successful.
That's what I did, I didn't tell anyone
that I was doing social media
till they found out by themselves
and they said, oh my
God, you're doing this,
and how you're doing this.
So what you're doing in
my opinion is correct,
because you're happy that way.
You don't want people judging you
and telling you and
stopping you from doing it.
So do it in the shadow
till like you're ready,
or like they find out by themself.
- Hey Robert.
- [Robert] Yeah?
- I'm gonna take a little bit,
I'm gonna poke on this one a little bit,
in a good way, I think.
I think this might, I hope
this brings you value, brother.
One thing that I'm very passionate about
is not dwelling on the
reality of a situation.
Your reality is, this is
where we are right now
in the current state of America
and where you were born
and how it all went down.
That's not something you can control.
And to your point when
you're in your situation
it's fearful and you feel
completely out of control,
I think, remind yourself
that even people that are,
let's say from your perspective,
fortunate that they were born here.
Somebody who was born here
in the last 10 minutes,
had their child die in a car accident.
Somebody that was born here
had a million dollars stolen
out of their bank account
by their drug addict aunt
and will never get it back.
Somebody lost her dad,
somebody just got their blood work back
and they're chronically ill in perpetuity
and will be dying this year.
Like you know the reality is,
this is your reality and it's not fun
and I'm sure many people listening
and outside the world
have lots of judgments,
but this is just you in your head.
And one of the things you need to play,
look one of the reasons I'm super happy,
is I'm always prepared every day
for my world to be shattered.
I think every day, every
day, like what happens
if everybody that I love dies
today in a crazy accident,
and in a weird way it makes me happy.
And I think I'm gonna
give you a left-field one,
but one of the things that I would do
if you're my best friend,
I'd probably say this to you every day,
I would say, bro, just
make pretend everyday
that you're not gonna live in America.
- [Robert] Right.
- You know, because once that
becomes more real to you,
of living in Canada or Denmark or Brazil,
or all these other
wonderful places, you know,
once that becomes real to you,
all of a sudden
the thing that feels the
scariest in the world
loses some of its teeth.
- [Robert] Oh, appreciate that,
that's actually one of
the coping mechanisms
my wife and I use, like.
She lives in Spain
and that's where she
learned how to speak Spanish
and all of the big connections
that I heard and I had,
that was like, she knew Spanish,
and so that's what we dream about,
hey if anything ever happens to me,
go to Spain, you know.
And I just wanted to add something,
I was like, my biggest
fear was, you know, hiding,
and right after that was
anybody knowing my secret.
And the way I broke through that
or I'm currently breaking through that
is two years ago I met
my mentor Ryan Levesque,
and I went to Ask Live
and I stood up and I told everybody,
there were a thousand people there,
that I was undocumented,
and today I'm in his new book, you know,
like it's weird for me to know
that there are thousands
of people out there
that know my secret now.
- Well, guess what, good news,
you've now taken back the leverage.
- [Robert] Yeah.
- And Spain's got fucking
amazing wine, bro.
(laughs)
Brother, you've already won this game,
I hope you realize it's not thousands,
it actually means with
Internet, everybody.
The second you get that through your head,
it's gonna get even more fun.
- [Robert] And that's I'm dealing with,
'cause like that fear of
hiding is so intensified
because of that.
- A hundred percent, because now you've,
but this is actually,
no, but what's amazing is
you've actually really won.
What you've done is taken control.
You actually were not capable
of dealing with the hiding,
so you actually subconsciously
exposed yourself,
which puts you in a better spot.
The only thing left now
is the knock on the door
that you're not looking forward to.
- [Robert] Exactly.
- I'm aware, bro, listen--
- [Robert] Because of my kids, you know.
- Of course, bro,
start getting your kids
pumped about Spain.
- [Robert] We are like for real.
- I believe you, bro.
- [Robert] Only like three days ago,
we were looking at houses--
- Bro, listen here, listen to me,
the biggest thing that I'm hoping happens
during this incredible year
of openness, of communication,
a lot of political unrest
and a lot of dealing with truth
that society's going through,
is that it becomes one big
game of not judging others.
I'm sure, inevitably, with
what you're going through,
you're probably at the,
you probably think about things
a little bit like I do in some ways.
You're probably at the coffee shop
and you hear somebody complaining
about the dumbest shit in the world
and you're sitting there saying
I would trade anything to be with you,
switch with you, so I wouldn't have,
but what you don't know,
is you think you want to
switch with that person,
but that person's wife
dies from a brain aneurysm
the next day.
I believe in what I'm saying,
I think a lot of people
listening right now
and saying, Gary, you're
using such extremes.
Fine, I'm using extremes.
You know what scares me more
than a lot of scary things
like being undocumented or other things?
What about the hidden mental health issues
that everybody on earth is
walking around with, right?
Like we just don't know
anything about anybody else
and so all of a sudden, I don't know,
me thinking that everybody else
has it just as bad and just as good
has kind of weirdly eliminated
my ability to judge,
which has just put me in
such a crazy mental place
that I'm desperate for everybody else
to start at least flirting with.
Like the second you think for a second,
that you wish you were somebody else,
just remember you don't
know jack shit about them.
- [Robert] Right.
- [Noor] Hundred percent.
- [Robert] Actually the first thing
that you don't know that they're here,
but tomorrow they might
lose their children,
that was one of the things
that Ryan went through,
where he almost died
and like he was never gonna, you know,
he came to terms with his mortality,
that's what broke me out of my hypnosis
that my life was shitty.
- That's right.
- [Robert] Because I'm not dying.
- If every person that has a child,
'cause guess what, I'd much rather die
than have my child die,
if everybody in the world that has a child
actually made pretend
every day and felt it
and were that connected with themselves
that they could feel it,
of the loss of their child,
the world would be a much better place.
- [Robert] Totally.
- All right, brother,
thank you, thank you.
Let's get another call in.
- I didn't understand his
issue, because of my--
- I know you didn't, which is
why I jumped in and helped.
- Yeah, that's nice, I was like--
- Yeah, we're a team here.
- [Voice Message] The number
you have dialed is not--
- I love how you're like, I understand--
- Talk to me about being so big,
so how many subscribers
do you have on YouTube?
- 11 something.
- Okay, 11.4 million.
Talk to me about the rest
of your social media,
how you thought about it,
did you feel insecurity that
you were so big on YouTube
and not as big in other places,
did that hold you back
from starting things,
how have other things gone,
obviously you know we've
interacted a little bit
on Instagram, so how's that coming--
- I was focused on YouTube
for the longest time,
because I started on YouTube
and I really love YouTube.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- And then I had Instagram,
but I never cared,
I archived a lot of pictures
that's just like random
things I used to post.
And last year actually when
I took Instagram seriously
and I remember you followed me a year ago,
I was like a million and something
or like almost two millions,
and when I really focused,
now I have like four point something,
so I believe when you're a creative person
you can make it on any--
- I agree.
(phone ringing)
- And Instagram is a very
very very important platform.
- [Gary] I agree, it has
a lot of attention today.
- Today.
We don't know like--
- If you were much older you
would have dominated my space.
- [Noor] Yeah.
- I mean it.
- [Caller] Hello.
- Hello, Austin, it's Gary
Vee, you're on with Noor.
- [Austin] Hey Gary Vee, hey
Noor, how you guys doing?
- Hi, how are you?
- We're well, Austin, what's
your question, brother?
- [Austin] I'm doing
great, I'm doing great.
I'm super excited you
guys called me actually,
that's so awesome.
- Happy to do it.
- [Austin] But, yeah my question,
I am 21 years old,
I actually live right outside
of Seattle Washington,
so just like Nora was saying earlier.
- Awesome.
- [Austin] And I had a
question just for Gary,
about what quality content
is to you when you say that,
and also your opinion
on influencer marketing.
- I think influencer
marketing has just started
and it's nowhere close
to dying or being passé.
We have always taken other
people's word-of-mouth
and I think we are in the
earliest earliest stages
of influencer marketing.
And I believe that the day I
die in a 100 years from now
that influencer marketing
will be part of it
because word-of-mouth has
always been a part of it.
So early stages, some
will rise, some will fall,
quality will rise to the top,
there'll be more long tail.
I believe that the kids
that are eight years old now
that aspire to be influencer marketers
may not end up getting
to normalized level,
but it might be a side
hustle that they always have,
that every average dad,
every average dad in the
world at 41 years old,
that's nine year olds now,
will be in play to get
a $50 gift certificate
or a free item to post on
their Instagram or YouTube
of the day 32 years from now,
because that's actually
how it's always worked,
so that's that.
As far as quality, brother,
you know, quality is
completely subjective.
And the audience speaks.
So for me it's only the audience.
However it starts with me
and what I want to make.
Which is exactly what I was pushing Noor
about 15 to 20 minutes ago.
She knows what the audience wants,
she's gotten so big now
that she's only making
what the audience wants.
- Right.
- I know.
- [Noor] That's right.
- And so I want her to take
the next step in her career,
so now I'm trying to push her
to put out what she wants.
My audience did not
want, by any indication
garage sale videos.
My audience by any indication
did not want baseball card videos.
It didn't want parenting advice,
it didn't want relationship advice,
it didn't want business advice.
My first five years was
putting out a video on YouTube
every day of the week from 2006 to 2011,
five days a week, excuse me,
and I only made wine videos.
And the first business
video I started making,
people left comments saying
stay in your lane, wine boy.
- You get that too, oh my God!
- [Gary] Everybody gets that forever.
- Yeah, when you do something new.
- [Austin] Just adding on to
that, because I'm curious,
you know, being 21,
I have been really thinking
of some practical ways
that I can use to--
- Yes, I think that
you should make a video
about every business in town.
- [Austin] Okay.
- You're a real estate broker?
- [Austin] Yeah, yes sir.
- You're trying to sell people homes
in a certain area, right?
- [Austin] Yes.
- If you become the voice
that understands every small business,
every teacher that goes
to the school district
and teaches the kids,
every pothole on Main Street,
every history lesson of the subway store
that's been there since 1947,
if you become the social
media mayor of your area
and local newspaper of your area,
you will become the number
one realtor in your area.
You've unlimited content, bro,
until you review every single business
and every single public space
and every single street
and tree and flower
and teacher and firefighter
and public servant,
until you interview
every single one of them
you have unlimited content.
- [Austin] That's a
great bite, man (laughs).
- I know.
Now the question is, are
you gonna execute on it?
- [Austin] Yes, you know,
I listen to you a lot, Gary.
- I appreciate it.
- [Austin] I feel like
you said it before too,
like I've already said all this stuff,
like at this point I'm just
saying the same thing over,
you know, until people
can kind of get it more
and maybe a different piece of content
will hit people differently.
- And that's why I believe in access.
The reason I'm giving you
access to me right now
is maybe you have watched the fact
that I said be the mayor
of your town in real estate
from a real estate video
in 2011, which I did.
And here we are eight years later,
maybe you consumed it three
years ago or last week.
But the fact that you have access
and we're having this
connection right now,
this might be the way you need to hear it.
I don't get to judge how,
like that's my big thing with my audience,
people ask me all the time,
especially good friends, inner circle,
they're like, bro,
aren't you tired of saying the same shit?
Like if they don't fucking
get it, let it alone,
I'm like you're audacious.
I'm like, you have
nothing to tell the world,
I have something to tell the world.
I need this, this makes me happy,
I want to leave a legacy,
I like positive reinforcement
and if that means I have
to say the same thing
until the day I die in
84,000 different ways
over 800,000 different days,
then I will do that.
Because I don't get to judge
how you consume it, bro,
I just have to keep putting
it out in different ways
and access to the audience
is one of the biggest ways I know how.
No influencer wants to do it,
'cause it's hard, it's
not scalable, they think.
I think it's the most important.
Yesterday I was fucking pissed,
three canceled flights,
had to go back through customs,
'cause I was in fucking Canada,
that was the worst, like
you get kicked off the plane
and then you have to wait
in customs for 40 minutes,
and what do I do while
I'm waiting for my car?
I go on Instagram live
and provide more value.
I also happen to be running
a 200 million-dollar company
with a thousand employees.
So anyway, that's the answer, brother.
- [Austin] Yeah, thank
you, Gary, thank you Nora,
I appreciate it.
- Thank you.
Wow.
- Everybody's calling you
Nora, does everybody do that?
- Nora?
Yeah, it's easier for them.
But my name is Noor.
- I'm aware, that's why I'm asking.
Right, Sinon?
Do you know we called
Sinon, Cenan, or Seenan,
for two and a half years?
- Oh my God.
- And then we went to
Cartier, he was like,
by the way one last thing,
we're having this meeting
he goes, you don't
pronounce my name right.
I'm like what the fuck?
- He told me, you're the first one here
that pronounced my name right.
- [Gary] Well you've got that, you get it.
- Because we're Middle Eastern?
- Of course, your tongue goes that way.
You should see when I
get going with Russian,
I can really fuckin' drill it.
(laughing)
- Who's this?
- [Andy] Manal from Dubai.
- Manal?
- [Team Member] Nike girl,
Manal says she's a Nike Girl.
Oh yeah, I know Manal.
- [Noor] Manal from Dubai?
- Hopefully it'll connect,
we'll wait a few more seconds.
- [Voice Message] The
number you have dialed
is not in service.
- Try one more time.
Did you get your question
off that you had written
or did you have something?
- Okay, so I have a
question that I really,
like a lot of people ask,
it's what you say for people
who have unsupportive parents,
like their parents doesn't support them.
- [Gary] What about it?
- Yeah, what about it,
what's your advice to them?
- To respectfully not listen to them.
- [Noor] Really?
- Yeah, parents love their children.
And a lot of parents and
especially non-American cultures,
but in America too they
do it in a different way,
treat their kids like products.
And also feel like their kids
are a huge reflection on them
which is where it breaks down.
But ultimately from what I've observed,
I believe that most parents
are unbelievably proud of a child
when they are successful in
not listening to their parents.
And so you win either way.
Here's why, I'll explain in a minute.
Hello.
- [Caller] Hello.
- Hello, it's Gary, how are you?
- [Caller] Hi Gary, oh my God,
this is like one of the
best days of 2019 already.
- I love it, say hello to Noor.
- [Caller] Hi Noor!
- Hi Manal, how are you?
- [Gary] Hi Manal.
- [Manal] I'm very good, habibi,
Eid Mubarak in advance.
(speaks in foreign language)
- [Gary] Hell, yeah!
(laughing)
- What can we answer for you?
- [Manal] Okay, so one direct question,
so as a woman of the Middle East,
I find it so hard to maintain
my sort of like no fucks given attitude,
because I come off as a bitch basically,
all the time when I stand up for myself
or when I tell the truth
or when I achieve so much
that people are so scared of me
and what I find happening
is that my circle keeps
getting smaller and smaller
and then no one's shed
a tear once for me and--
- Stop listening, stop listening
to those insecure dudes!
- Yeah, I totally understand what you say,
'cause I've been through the same thing.
- [Gary] Of course, you guys have.
- You gotta ignore them and that's it,
you can't do anything,
they're just insecure.
I had a boy that I liked
and he told me I don't
know how to deal with you,
I don't know what to do with you.
- [Manal] Babe, I'm 39, I'm still single
because everyone finds me,
you know, intimidating.
I know, like dude, I would
love to get with you,
just give me a chance to get to know me.
You know, I'm not just
all about the social media bling-bling,
all these marathons and mountains,
there's a human being
behind all these successes.
- Look, listen, to both of you,
and to me and to everybody.
The answer to all,
if we're going on personal relationships
and if we're talking,
if we're ragging on insecure boys
which is the dominant percentage of boys,
and by the way, the dominant
percentage of girls,
it takes two to tango, right?
So the reality is, to your point,
you've probably stumbled
across a ton of insecure guys
who can't handle an alpha woman,
but as you know, and I
know hundreds of them,
let alone tens of them,
I know intimately hundreds of alpha women
who have found many men
who are able to handle that.
So what I would say is a couple of things.
One, of course, there's a
staggering amount of people
that are insecure
and can't deal with an alpha woman.
By the way, there's a lot of women
that can't handle alpha guys,
even though it's more common
and we see that, we all look at that.
However, you also have to be thoughtful
about if you're at a place now,
it's just that, you listen,
you come across from me from afar
and even the way you're
even talking right now,
the biggest question you
have to figure out is,
how happy or unhappy are you about it.
One of the things that I think
is going to become a very
fascinating conversation
over the next century,
is, does one need to
become married, right?
Like, my biggest question for you is,
how happy are you right now?
That's the question.
- [Manal] Am I supposed
to answer that right away?
- Yes, you are.
- [Manal] I'm very very like
proud of my achievements,
but then they do not tick
the Arab society's boxes
and that's why sometimes I feel unhappy,
like, you know, I always say
- The pressure.
when I share I'm going
to be in a marathon,
or climbing a mountain
on a WhatsApp group to my mom,
I don't receive a response.
- I get it.
- [Manal] You didn't even get it.
- Listen,
no, you're right, listen, let me rephrase,
I don't get it because I'm not
a Middle eastern woman, but--
- I get it.
- [Gary] Of course, you do,
you guys can connect to that.
- [Manal] Thank you.
- But you'll appreciate this,
and I think this is
something we all have to do.
None of us get the other person
if you don't go through that experience,
but that goes for everybody.
The reason I get it,
I'm gonna say it again,
this is a very micro thing.
Noor, listen to me, I am 43 years old.
In 1985, 1989, 1992,
when you got these in Fs,
the entire world said
you were a fucking loser.
There wasn't a single person.
Kids don't grow up with that now.
Now there's entrepreneurship.
So like my whole life
has been misunderstood.
Do you ladies know
that almost everybody in
the advertising world,
the business I'm in,
thinks I'm a charlatan and
completely full of shit?
Like everybody has pushback.
I, when I'm called a charlatan
or snake oil salesman,
have to be thoughtful of
do they have any point?
I process it and then I move on.
And I think what you
need to think about is,
listen, nobody will ever convince me
that there's not one,
you can tell me 98% of
people see it that way,
but you will never convince me
because I've seen it too many times.
There's always one, what
are you doing about it
to put yourself in a
position to find that one,
is the biggest thing
that you can focus on.
Really, you can't focus on other people.
Nobody else, I have no
interest in convincing
or forcing anyone else to be anything.
I focus on myself
and then I say yes or no based on me.
And that's what you need
to do in this scenario.
- Yeah, and don't let the pressure
make you make wrong decisions, you know,
that's the most important thing.
- [Manal] I just find it
very hard to stay on track
with all these people
telling me negative--
- Fuck them, fuck them, fuck them.
- [Manal] That I'm a human
being at the end, you know.
- Fuck them fuck them,
and by the way, if anybody's listening
and they're struggling
with that, that's on you.
It's fuck them, comma,
get your shit together.
Like living your life based
on other people's opinions
is the quickest way to
live an unhappy life.
And when you've audiences
like the three of us do,
you can't take the good without the bad.
You love the positive reinforcement,
you love the comments that
say you're the greatest
and you changed their life.
You then have to accept
that people are gonna say
you're a piece of shit,
that's the cost of the fucking game.
And that's how I do it,
listen, like all of us are being judged
and in different times,
in different spaces,
I'm very similar genetically
to my great-grandfather, right?
He just happened to be
born in Soviet Russia
as a Jewish man,
which meant he was ridiculed and beat up
and put in jail for 11 years.
I was born in America,
where I didn't have to deal with that.
So obviously I have a different scenario
and obviously we're different I'm sure,
no two dudes are the same,
but we can only deal with our realities,
there's no changing our realities.
What you need to focus on
is none of the outside
and only on the inside
put yourself in a position
to find what you're looking for,
instead of dwelling on
what the outside is not giving you.
- [Manal] 100 percent,
thank you, Gary, love it.
- You understand, every second you think,
oh, my culture doesn't get it,
oh, these guys don't get it,
oh, that boy I like doesn't get it,
every second you're spending on that,
you're not spending on
getting what you want.
- You're wasting your time.
And if you think he doesn't get it,
then that's it, he's gone,
don't waste your time on him.
You know what I find something,
like we waste a lot of time
thinking that it's gonna work
and it's not gonna work.
When they tell you or like they show signs
that it's not gonna work
- Get the fuck out.
that's it, X, and then next,
you move on with your life
and that's how you don't
waste your time, Manal.
- It's having conviction
without being delusional.
Stick to your guns,
but make sure you're
listening to the feedback.
I always think I'm right
until enough people tell me I'm wrong,
not a couple.
- [Manal] Yeah, but what's enough?
Like how much is enough though?
How do you quantify that?
- Enough is when a bunch of people
that don't have any vested interest
have a thought and I
respect their thought.
Like the reality is,
for me enough is like almost everybody,
like thousands, you know,
because otherwise I'm
gonna stick to my guns.
I think the bigger question, oh,
that's three more of a business answer.
In relationship answers it's one.
Every time I sensed my whole life
that somebody wasn't interested in me,
I didn't spend any time on it.
I'll be very honest.
I never chased a single girl
because I was like excited,
and I mean this because--
- [Manal] Was it because
you were Gary Vee?
- No, but everybody sees the end,
nobody saw the process.
Nobody in my high school or college
thought I was gonna be Gary Vee.
I thought I was gonna
be and that's the point.
- [Noor] Yes.
That's the fucking point.
You know how much happiness I have
that every girl that ever
knew that I had some interest
that didn't have interest
now has to deal with the ramifications?
(laughing)
It's a delicious taste.
All right, I gotta get out of here.
Thanks for the call.
Noor, I adore you,
you get to ask the question of the day.
What question do you
have for the audience?
- For the audience?
Oh my God.
What's stopping you from
following your dream,
like the dream that you really wanna do,
what's stopping you?
- And I never jump in on
question day, as my team knows,
but you just asked such a great question
and it was such a great
podcast, show, episode,
tell the truth even if you
have to create a fake account
so your parents or sibling
or spouse or children
don't see it,
create a fake account, a burner,
and tell the truth.
Actually saying the truth out loud
impacts humans tremendously.
Noor, thank you so much.
- Thank you, thank you so much.
- Such a pleasure, you were amazing.
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
The incredible Noor stops
by on today's episode.
Awesome.
- Oh my God, that was amazing.